let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
is the number let's take our first
caller from the 2 1 4 area code caller
what's your name were you calling from
my name is Dave I'm calling from Dallas
Texas great what time today and I've
noticed that when caught well notice
that when talking about Russian
interference in our elections an
election a lot of Republicans so in the
caveat that while they think it happened
they don't think it affected the outcome
of the election yeah and I think the
ones that are saying that realized
Trump's probably not going to be able to
fulfill his son either because he'll be
in peace or he will simply step down
when he realizes he's about to be
impeached and I think they're setting us
up to just accept Mike Pence as our
president so my question is this in the
event that Trump loses office for having
colluded with the Russians should
America simply accept Mike Pence is our
new president or shall we demand that it
be handled like most competitions where
when the winner was founded it cheated
they're stripped of their coddle and the
second place winner is in being the
winner which in this case she actually
was the winner she had three million
more votes in hell yeah she would expect
the whole new election listen we should
not expect a whole new election what we
should your make there's no point you've
made that at its core I could I could
tell tell you is logically wrong
that being said Mike Pence is going to
be the next president of the United
States if you see a resignation
impeachment or any other means by which
Donald Trump is removed from office
during during the next three years and
ten months I guess or whatever the case
may be but I want to go back to the
first thing you said Dave which is
Republicans are saying even if Russia
did the hacking it didn't affect the
outcome of the election I actually think
that there's a reason for saying that
when Republicans say that they continue
to keep the focus of Russian
interference only on the hacking but the
hacking at this point is like 5% of the
entire Russia collusion we've had Paul -
Paul Manafort resignation the Michael
Flynn resignation Jeff session now who
knows what ultimately is going to happen
with Jeff Sessions there's so much more
here than just the hacking that I
actually think
a line that you accurately recreated for
us which is even if Russia hacked it
didn't change the outcome of the
election it may be true it may not be
true I believe it's a way to keep the
focus only on the hacking which is only
a fraction of the Russia story right now
I don't know if I agree with that I
actually think that they are afraid that
people are going to rise up when this
happens half the country more than half
the country actually did not vote for
Donald Trump or Mike dance they voted
for Hillary Clinton yeah I think they
probably have some fear that there's
only people marching in the streets
raising hell if they end up just trying
to put my I mean there's just too much
at stake here we have Supreme Court
nominations and all that to let Mike
Pence be our president I feel like but I
think there's no guidelines are really
afraid of that there's no guidelines in
the Constitution though that would call
for another election or for the loser to
become president in that case if it came
out that Mike Pence was also involved in
the Russia story then the person that
would become the next president would be
the Speaker of the House which is Paul
Ryan president Paul Ryan there there's a
scary thought huh hey Paul Ryan was not
a big fan of Trump to begin with maybe
this is all part of Paul Ryan's master
plan it could be I don't know anything
in the Constitution either yeah I just
don't think there's anything in the
Constitution either that says that a guy
who cheats to win should get the code
the officers you know they dabble oh I
don't know hey when it's Republicans in
the House and Senate of the party of
course you can compute it doesn't matter
anymore I appreciate the call thank you
so much a good good topic and I think
it's going to continue being an issue no
doubt about it